Générique
...
-Bonsoir
et bienvenue sur LCP
pour cette soirée autour des 1 an
de la guerre en Ukraine.
La justice peut-elle passer
dans un pays en guerre ?
On se pose la question ce soir
avec mes invitées,
dont les réalisatrices
Marine Courtade
et Ilioné Schultz,
qui ont réalisé ce document inédit
que l'on va voir.
Comment enquêter
quand l'urgence est la survie ?
Comment rendre justice aux victimes
murées dans le silence ?
"Crimes sexuels de guerre,
documenter l'horreur",
un document inédit pour LCP.
Regardez.
Souffle menaçant
Musique dramatique
...
-Galina a osé parler,
à visage découvert,
parce qu'elle n'est plus si jeune,
parce qu'elle n'a peut-être
plus rien à perdre
et surtout,
au nom de tous les autres.
Car depuis le début
de l'invasion russe,
des cas de violences sexuelles
sont rapportés :
des femmes, des hommes,
des enfants...
Combien sont-ils ?
Impossible de donner
une estimation.
...
Ici, à Kiev, au bureau
du procureur général, les dossiers
arrivent
au compte-gouttes.
8 procureurs sont chargés
depuis septembre
d'enquêter exclusivement
sur les crimes sexuels
commis dans cette guerre.
Une première dans un conflit
en cours,
mais pour l'instant,
155 dossiers seulement
sont instruits.
Dans le fracas des bombes,
l'urgence
n'est pas à la parole.
En ukrainien
-La priorité,
c'est de survivre.
-J'espère que dans le futur,
les gens parleront
plus facilement.
Pour l'instant, ils ont surtout peur
que les occupants reviennent.
-Comment enquêter
lorsque le quotidien des habitants
est rythmé par les combats ?
Comment repérer les victimes,
réduites au silence
sous le poids de la honte ?
Et comment
leur rendre justice ?
...
-Je mets mon sac sous le vôtre.
-Oui, pas de souci.
-La règle numéro 1
pour les procureurs,
c'est désormais
de quitter leur bureau
et de privilégier le terrain.
A tour de rôle,
ils sillonnent les zones de guerre
en quête de témoignages.
Ce matin,
c'est au tour d'Olga.
Une longue route
pour se rendre à Izioum,
occupée par les Russes
pendant presque 6 mois.
Située dans la région
de Kharkiv,
à l'est du pays,
elle est aujourd'hui
à 70 kilomètres du front.
-La région de Kharkiv
est bombardée
presque tous les jours.
Je n'ai pas peur,
nos vies dépendent
de la volonté divine.
Chacun sa destinée.
Et moi, c'est ma responsabilité
et mon travail
d'aller aider les gens.
J'en tire
une certaine fierté.
-Pourquoi est-ce important
pour vous de venir ici ?
-Les gens se méfient
des autorités judiciaires,
alors nous venons
au contact des victimes
pour qu'ils ne nous craignent pas,
pour qu'ils n'aient pas peur
de témoigner.
Ces témoignages sont très importants
pour notre travail.
-La ville porte
les stigmates des combats.
Les Russes ont fui
il y a seulement cinq mois,
un passé à vif
qu'Olga va tenter de sonder.
Sa mission commence
dans le bureau du maire.
Conversations en ukrainien
...
-Je suis procureure.
Ma fonction,
c'est d'enquêter
sur les violences sexuelles
commises
au cours de la guerre.
-Oui, on va avoir
des choses pour vous.
Vous êtes peut-être déjà au courant,
mais ici, on a déjà recensé
beaucoup de violences sexuelles
sur les femmes.
Entrez.
...
Voici Nadya, directrice du service
social de la ville d'Izioum.
Avec Nadya Patrivna, on prend
toutes ces histoires très à coeur.
-Ce n'est pas possible
de faire autrement.
...
Vous avez plus de contact
que nous
avec les habitants.
Les gens vous parlent
plus facilement qu'à nous.
Si vous entendez parler d'un cas
qui concerne notre domaine,
faites-nous signe
et on viendra.
-Je peux avoir votre numéro ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
Je vais vous l'écrire.
-Les gens
vont-ils se confier
à un procureur
qu'ils ne connaissent pas ?
Olga veut rassurer.
-On ne pose pas
de questions brusques.
On sait qu'une victime a besoin
de temps avant de parler.
Quand elle se sentira
vraiment prête,
alors à ce moment-là,
nous reviendrons la voir
et nous irons au fond des choses
avec elle.
Merci. Au revoir.
-Pour se faire connaître,
les procureurs ont fait
imprimer des brochures.
Et le meilleur endroit
pour trouver du monde,
c'est au point
d'aide humanitaire.
Notre caméra
reste en retrait.
-Bureau du procureur général.
Désolée de vous déranger.
Pour les femmes qui ont été
victimes de violences sexuelles,
voilà des brochures.
Vous y trouverez
toutes les informations
pour obtenir de l'aide.
Il y a un numéro d'urgence
dans les brochures roses.
Bonjour.
Bureau du procureur général.
-Olga en profite
pour poser des questions,
au hasard des rencontres.
-Avez-vous été témoin
de tortures de civils ?
-Non ! Nous sommes restées
tout le temps chez nous.
Ca tirait de partout !
Les bombes volaient
au-dessus de nos têtes.
-Olga le sait, ce sont les femmes
qui parleront plus facilement.
-Les hommes, eux, sont plus fermés.
Même s'ils ont été victimes
de violences sexuelles,
ils ne le diront jamais
comme ça,
dans la rue,
à une étrangère.
Avez-vous été témoin
ou victime
d'un crime ?
-Non, Dieu merci !
Musique de tension
-Ce jour-là,
Olga ne recueillera
ni information, ni indice,
mais elle a semé
des graines.
Elle reviendra ici,
si des victimes se décident
à parler et à se faire aider.
-En tant que représentant
judiciaire,
notre but, bien sûr,
c'est que la victime
obtienne
l'aide psychologique
et morale nécessaire.
Il faut que les criminels
soient punis,
que la victime puisse
avoir la satisfaction
de savoir que
son bourreau a été puni.
En distribuant
ces brochures,
on veut aussi
montrer aux gens
que la société
ne les a pas abandonnés.
...
-Ne pas abandonner
les victimes,
c'est l'objectif
de cette unité spéciale.
Des victimes qui se sont
trop longtemps et trop souvent
senties livrées
à elles-mêmes.
Un coq chante.
Dans l'ouest de l'Ukraine,
à Polyana,
loin des zones de combats...
Conversations en ukrainien
...
...Galina,
celle qui a porté plainte,
vient de parcourir
700 kilomètres
pour retrouver les femmes
de l'association SEMA.
Le viol qu'elle a subi,
elle leur a déjà raconté.
Aujourd'hui,
elle est venue
parler de la suite.
Quand son village
a été libéré,
elle a demandé une aide médicale
pour ses douleurs au ventre.
Mauvaise surprise :
au cabinet du médecin,
ce sont des hommes du SBU,
les services de renseignement
ukrainiens,
qui se sont occupés d'elle.
-Un de ces hommes
m'a dit de me déshabiller
pendant que la gynécologue restait
loin, dans un coin de la pièce.
Quand j'ai écarté les jambes,
il a dit :
"Ah, oui.
Le cas est très clair, là."
Et l'autre a fait des photos.
La docteure a tout vu,
mais elle n'a pas bougé.
Je lui ai dit :
"J'ai besoin d'un traitement."
J'ai demandé
tous les tests possibles
pour le sida, les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles...
Il m'avait fait ça
dans de telles conditions...
La gynécologue m'a dit
qu'elle ne pouvait pas le faire,
à moins que je paye.
Du coup,
j'ai emprunté de l'argent
à mon voisin.
-Merci beaucoup d'avoir partagé
ton histoire avec nous.
Tu mets en évidence
un vrai problème.
-Comment le gouvernement
a pu m'abandonner comme ça ?
-A partir de maintenant,
tout va aller mieux.
-Oui, ça va.
J'ai passé tellement de temps
toute seule, et maintenant...
Je suis très contente
de vous avoir, les filles.
-Ces femmes qui la soutiennent
ont elles aussi subi
des violences sexuelles,
quelques années avant Galina,
dès 2014,
dans la région du Donbass.
Elles ont ensuite créé
cette association pour s'épauler.
8 ans après,
elles ont enfin le sentiment
que les choses
commencent un peu à bouger.
-On n'était pas nombreuses
à pouvoir en parler ouvertement.
Et personne ne comprenait vraiment
notre souffrance.
Depuis que l'invasion
à grande échelle a commencé,
j'ai l'impression
que le monde entier
et les autorités ukrainiennes
commencent enfin
à nous croire, à croire
ce qui nous est arrivé.
-Avec ce qu'elle a vécu,
Iryna est persuadée
qu'elle trouvera les mots
pour libérer la parole
mieux qu'un procureur
ou qu'un policier.
Depuis le printemps,
elle se rend
dans les territoires libérés,
en quête de témoignages.
Accompagnée de son mari,
elle prend aujourd'hui
la direction de Kherson,
une ville située
en pleine zone de guerre,
sur la ligne de front,
au sud du pays.
-Ben tiens, il y a
une station-service, là,
elle est
complètement détruite.
-C'est comme quand on est allés
à Boutcha.
-Iryna et son mari n'arrivent pas
les mains vides.
Puisqu'il est si difficile
d'obtenir des tests,
eux vont les mettre à disposition
des victimes.
-C'est absolument nécessaire
pour les femmes,
aujourd'hui.
Les femmes
taisent leurs viols
par peur du retour
des militaires russes.
Elles ne disent rien,
elles ne s'adressent même pas
à un médecin,
ce qui est dramatique,
si jamais
elles ont été infectées.
-Elle qui était
esthéticienne
est devenue
une militante convaincue.
Victime des séparatistes
pro-russes en 2014,
elle s'occupe désormais
à plein temps
de son association.
Son combat est une revanche
sur son histoire personnelle.
-Quand j'étais détenue,
j'ai subi un viol,
avec un sac sur la tête.
Je sais que je ne pourrai jamais
identifier ce type
qu'il ne sera jamais puni,
s'il est encore vivant.
Mon rêve,
c'est qu'à l'échelle
mondiale,
ça ne se reproduise
plus jamais.
-Avec le temps,
Iryna s'est constitué
un réseau d'informateurs.
On lui a parlé d'une femme
qui pourrait connaître
des victimes.
-Bonjour !
Oh, qu'il est mignon,
ce petit bout de chou
tout en bleu.
-Elle vit ici avec son mari
et un orphelin de guerre
qu'ils ont adopté.
-Je viens vous voir,
parce que vous circulez
dans la région, que vous parlez
avec les gens du coin.
Vous avez des contacts,
vous avez dû
entendre des choses.
Je voudrais vous demander...
-Oui, je comprends.
Il s'est passé plein de choses,
dans le coin.
Bon, il y a bien des femmes
qui ont été consentantes
par ici.
-Oui, c'était la même chose
dans la région de Kiev.
Il y a des femmes
comme ça partout.
Mais nous,
ce qui nous intéresse,
ce sont les femmes
qu'on a forcées.
Ces personnes-là,
on doit les aider.
-La conversation prend alors
une tournure inattendue.
-Ca m'est arrivé à moi.
Mon mari ne veut pas
que je le raconte,
mais on a été dénoncés.
On a été dénoncés
pour avoir aidé
l'armée ukrainienne.
Lorsqu'ils sont arrivés,
j'ai passé deux jours
dans leur sous-sol.
Au début, ils m'ont électrocutée
avec un truc comme ça.
Je n'ai pas pu bien voir,
ma tête était couverte,
puis je suis tombée
dans les pommes.
Ils m'ont violée.
Ils ont fini par me libérer.
Et là,
ils ont même voulu m'aider.
-Oui, pour se déculpabiliser.
-Oui, c'est ça.
C'est mon histoire.
-Iryna découvre
que c'est une victime.
Elle connaît la procédure.
-Mais dites-moi,
vous en avez parlé au procureur
sans que votre mari
ne soit au courant ?
-Seulement au SBU.
-Seulement aux services
de renseignement ?
C'est bien,
mais c'est le bureau
du procureur
qui collecte
les témoignages.
C'est lui qui monte
les dossiers.
-En fait, je ne suis pas allée voir
le procureur,
parce que vous savez,
mon mari souffre beaucoup
de ne pas avoir pu
me protéger.
C'est aussi pour ça
que je ne voulais pas
qu'il assiste
à cette conversation.
-Alors regardez, ça,
c'est pour vous, de ma part.
Je vais vous laisser aussi
ces boîtes,
bien que bientôt périmées.
Ce sont des autotests.
-Iryna reviendra
le lendemain.
Elle veut persuader la victime
de parler au procureur.
Convaincre les femmes
de porter plainte
ne suffit pas.
Il faut accumuler les indices,
les preuves.
Lors des conflits passés,
trop de violences sexuelles
sont restées impunies,
faute d'enquêtes.
Dans les locaux
en état de siège du bureau
du procureur de Kiev,
une course contre la montre
s'engage.
La cheffe de l'unité spéciale,
Iryna Didenko,
doit, avec ses équipes,
aller vite,
ne rien laisser au hasard.
-Pour chaque dossier,
on arrive à récolter
des éléments différents.
Dans certains cas,
on a pu saisir les papiers,
les documents sur place.
On peut aussi retrouver
les traces d'ADN.
On a même mené
des examens médico-légaux
qui ont confirmé ces faits
de violences sexuelles.
On tente de récupérer
un maximum de preuves,
et pour ça,
il y a tout un protocole
à suivre.
On essaie aussi
de comprendre
comment ces criminels
de guerre
se sont déplacés,
où ils sont allés,
s'ils ont commis des crimes
dans plusieurs maisons,
parce qu'il arrive souvent
qu'ils passent de maison en maison
à la recherche de femmes.
-Enquêter pour nourrir
de futurs procès
et peut-être
envisager un jour
la création
d'un tribunal spécial.
Pour cela,
dossier après dossier,
les procureurs
tentent de remonter
la chaîne
des responsabilités.
Un travail difficile.
Pour s'orienter
dans les subtilités
du droit,
Ilya a pris un avocat.
Il a 22 ans,
et en avril dernier,
il a été violé
à un checkpoint
par des soldats russes.
Depuis ce traumatisme,
il a tenté de se suicider
à plusieurs reprises.
-Ilya connaît donc le prénom
du chef du groupe.
Un indice
qui a son importance.
Quel était son grade ?
A-t-il donné
ou reçu des ordres ?
De la réponse à ces questions
dépend
toute la procédure
judiciaire
lancée par son avocat.
-Pour ceux qui ont donné
des ordres,
ils pourront être traduits
à La Haye
devant la justice
internationale.
Et les autres,
ceux qui ont obéi
à cet ordre,
iront devant les tribunaux
ukrainiens.
Il est possible
que certains d'entre eux
soient aujourd'hui
dans nos prisons.
C'est pour ça
qu'on doit travailler ensemble
pour identifier ces gens
aussi vite que possible.
-Je suis sûr que la Cour pénale
internationale de La Haye
ne restera pas silencieuse.
Il n'y a pas de délai
de prescription pour ces cas ?
-Non, il n'y a pas de délai.
Même si les coupables
sont identifiés
et retrouvés dans très longtemps,
même dans 10 ans,
ce que je ne souhaite pas,
ils ne pourront pas échapper
à leurs responsabilités
car c'est un crime de guerre,
et un crime de guerre n'a pas
de date de prescription.
-C'est bon à entendre.
-L'avocat d'Ilya a lancé
une double procédure
auprès du procureur de Kiev
et devant la Cour pénale
internationale.
En Ukraine, la CPI a ouvert
une enquête en mars dernier.
Crimes de guerre,
crimes contre l'humanité,
génocides...
C'est elle qui déterminera
la qualification
des crimes sexuels.
-Tout le monde est prêt ?
-Pour étayer les dossiers
et aider à qualifier
ces crimes,
Anna et son équipe d'experts
se sont installés à Kiev.
Ils secondent les procureurs
dans leurs enquêtes.
Avec eux,
ils cherchent à prouver
le côté systématique
de ces viols.
En anglais
-Je travaille en ce moment
sur un cas
de violences sexuelles
commises sur une femme
dans la région de Kiev,
dans un village
qui a été occupé.
Et pour moi, il y a
un point intéressant :
l'auteur présumé appartiendrait
à la même unité
qu'un des types
de ton dossier, Denis.
Je pense
qu'il faut le signaler
au procureur.
Il y a des éléments
de systématisme.
-D'ailleurs,
les soldats russes,
quand ils occupaient
ce village,
ils cherchaient des signes
d'appartenance
à la nation ukrainienne :
des drapeaux, des tatouages,
par exemple.
Ces éléments
pourraient indiquer
une certaine intention.
Ca pourrait bien confirmer
cette théorie
que nous sommes
dans un crime systématique
et pas dans des incidents
aléatoires.
155 dossiers,
c'est encore trop peu
pour vraiment identifier
et confirmer des éléments
de systématisme,
mais quand on regarde la situation
région par région,
on commence à voir
que dans certaines zones,
il y a le même type de pratiques
criminelles qui se répètent,
et comment certains cas
sont très similaires.
-Ces violences sexuelles
font-elles partie
d'une stratégie ?
Sont-elles utilisées
comme une arme de guerre ?
Pour l'avocat,
il y a forcément
une responsabilité
des autorités russes.
En ukrainien
-Je suis persuadé
qu'il n'y a pas d'ordres écrits
qui diraient :
"Violez les citoyens ukrainiens."
Ce serait ridicule.
Mais en fait, c'est en eux,
dans leur tête.
Poutine et les autorités,
au plus haut niveau,
n'ont fait que mettre
de l'huile sur le feu
en disant que l'Ukraine
n'est pas un Etat,
et qu'ici, il y a
des mauvaises personnes
qui ne méritent pas de voir
leurs droits respectés.
-Malheureusement, sur l'intégralité
du territoire ukrainien,
un schéma se dessine :
partout où des militaires russes
étaient présents,
il y a eu des crimes
à caractère sexuel.
Personne n'est protégé :
ni les femmes, ni les hommes,
ni les enfants.
Cela touche tous les civils,
de 4 à 82 ans.
Pour nous, ces crimes sexuels
ne sont pas des cas isolés.
C'est une manoeuvre systématique
d'intimidation
et d'extermination
de la population locale.
-En Ukraine,
trois procès ont déjà eu lieu,
seulement par contumace.
Pour rendre justice
aux victimes,
procureurs, experts et associations
vont continuer
leur long travail d'enquête.
-Voilà donc
pour ce document inédit LCP
que vous avez réalisé,
Marine Courtade.
Bonsoir.
Et bonsoir, Ilioné Schultz.
On va revenir largement
sur la manière
dont vous avez pu suivre
cette procureure à Kiev
et sur la manière
dont vous avez recueilli
ces témoignages.
Céline Bardet,
ravie de vous accueillir.
Vous êtes juriste internationale,
spécialisée
sur les crimes internationaux.
Vous êtes la fondatrice de l'ONG
We are NOT Weapons of War
sur les crimes sexuels
dans les conflits.
Bonsoir, Véronique Nahoum-Grappe,
et bienvenue.
Anthropologue et ethnologue,
vous avez travaillé
sur ces questions
de crimes sexuels.
Marianna Perebenesiuk
est restée avec nous.
Vous êtes journaliste
ukrainienne indépendante.
Je me tourne
vers vous, Ilioné Schultz.
C'est rare
d'entendre des témoignages
comme ceux-là.
C'est difficile de porter plainte,
évidemment, dans un pays en guerre,
c'est aussi très difficile
d'accepter une caméra.
Vous avez déjà travaillé, je crois,
sur ces questions
de crimes sexuels.
Comment on arrive
à convaincre ces femmes
et cet homme qui témoignent
non seulement de le faire,
mais avec le regard d'une caméra ?
-Déjà, je crois
qu'effectivement,
le fait qu'on ait travaillé,
Marine et moi,
en Ukraine depuis longtemps,
et notamment aussi
sur les crimes sexuels
depuis 2016,
on a noué des contacts, forcément,
avec des interlocuteurs sur place,
ce qui facilite les choses.
Et puis...
La connaissance de ce sujet-là...
-C'est la justice ukrainienne,
et notamment cette procureure,
qui vous a amenées à ces femmes ?
-Je ne pensais pas forcément
à ces personnes-là,
mais les associations, les avocats
qui travaillent sur ce sujet
parce que, comme on l'a vu,
ces crimes...
Ces crimes sexuels ne datent pas
que de l'invasion à grande échelle.
Donc, il y a déjà ça.
Et puis après,
c'est aussi une posture
à avoir, je pense,
quand on rencontre
ces personnes-là :
faire comprendre
qu'on n'est pas là
pour les forcer,
pour obtenir absolument
un témoignage.
On est là pour raconter
l'histoire qu'ils veulent bien
nous confier
dans une posture respectueuse,
et sans jamais
forcer le questionnement.
-Oui, il y a une écoute
et un regard particuliers.
Marine, il y a
cette scène incroyable
où Iryna, cette femme ukrainienne
qui a été victime
d'un viol
avant cette guerre-là,
sillonne le pays
avec son association
et réalise, à la faveur
d'une conversation avec une femme
dans un village,
qu'elle a en face d'elle
une victime,
une victime de viol.
Cette scène-là, par exemple,
vous saviez ce qui allait
se passer en la tournant ?
-Non. Alors, ça,
ça a été une vraie surprise
pour le coup,
parce que nous, on partait
avec Iryna dans ce village-là
en pensant
qu'on allait rencontrer une témoin
qui allait nous amener
vers d'autres victimes
et nous raconter
ce qui s'était passé
dans ce village.
Et tout d'un coup,
elle éloigne son mari.
Nous, en plus,
on parle pas la langue.
On travaille dans ce pays,
mais on n'a pas appris
cette langue.
Et donc, on filme
la scène d'Iryna
avec cette femme.
On a notre traductrice
avec nous
qui, tout d'un coup, nous dit :
"Je crois qu'il se passe
quelque chose."
Et donc nous, à ce moment-là,
on se demande aussi
ce qu'on fait,
nous, journalistes,
alors que la caméra
est déjà en train de filmer,
et donc du coup,
on laisse les choses se passer.
Et puis après,
on a discuté avec cette femme
et on a un peu expliqué
ce qu'on faisait,
pourquoi on était là,
et discuté aussi de la question
de son anonymat.
C'est une vraie question
qui se pose
pour toutes les victimes
qu'on a rencontrées.
-Je précise que les lieux
ne sont pas nommés dans le film,
et évidemment,
elles ont donné leur accord.
C'est leur volonté
de témoigner
à visage découvert.
Encore une question.
Ce qui se dégage du film,
c'est à la fois
que c'est assez précurseur,
c'est assez fort
de voir une justice
en acte dans un Etat en guerre
et en même temps,
elle a un côté tellement artisanal
et fragile...
Est-ce que c'est l'état d'esprit
des procureurs, des magistrats ?
Ils sont conscients de ça ?
-Eux, ils sont
extrêmement motivés
de faire avancer
la justice,
les enquêtes, etc.
Cette unité spéciale
a été créée en septembre,
et en fait,
depuis qu'ils ont créé cette unité,
ils ont aussi vu
les limites
dans lesquelles
ils se sont retrouvés,
notamment sur la question
de la protection.
Là-dessus,
ils ont avancé
petit à petit
et ils ne cessent
de modifier leur fonctionnement
en fonction
des retours des victimes,
en fonction de ce qui se passe
sur place,
parce que la ligne de front
ne cesse de bouger,
et tout bouge.
En fait, ils sont
dans une adaptation permanente,
avec les limites
qu'implique le fait d'enquêter
dans un pays
dont le conflit continue.
-Céline Bardet,
comment vous réagissez à ce film ?
Evidemment, des témoignages,
vous en avez recueilli.
Au fond, il y a
cette dimension incroyable
d'une justice en acte
en temps de guerre.
Est-ce qu'elle va trop vite ?
Est-ce que ça vous inquiète ?
Est-ce que ça vous réjouit ?
-Ni l'un, ni l'autre,
c'est-à-dire que...
Si, quand même,
ça m'inquiète un peu.
Après, il faut comprendre
qu'il y a deux étapes.
Il y a la question
d'aller recueillir des témoignages,
c'est-à-dire
collecter des éléments
de preuve
et le processus de justice,
qui sont deux choses
différentes.
En effet,
l'Ukraine a mis en place
un processus de justice
au niveau national,
qui est un peu ralenti...
-C'est inédit,
pour un pays en guerre.
-C'est totalement inédit,
surtout à un niveau national.
Ca a posé des questions,
car je pense que
ces procès n'ont pas été...
Même avec la meilleure volonté
qui soit,
je pense que ces procès
n'ont pas été menés
dans les standards
dans lesquels ils auraient dû
être menés.
Mais c'est très compliqué,
en fait,
de faire ça
en plein conflit.
Et puis, l'autre question...
-Mais le fait
de le faire en plein conflit...
On voit bien qu'il y a
une question de justice.
Il y a une question politique,
aussi.
On va en parler,
mais ne serait-ce pas
le message
"l'impunité pour les crimes
de guerre, c'est fini" ?
C'est ça que ça renvoie,
comme message.
C'est maintenant
que les crimes sont commis
et qu'il faut avoir les preuves.
-Encore une fois,
avoir les preuves, c'est une chose.
Ca a été le positionnement
de Zelensky.
Il a dit :
"On va se défendre,
"on va résister
"et on répondra avec le droit."
Ils le font,
mais il n'empêche
qu'il faut avoir
des auteurs de crimes,
donc il faut les arrêter,
qu'ils soient sur place,
mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas.
Ensuite, il faut respecter
des standards,
car ce sont des crimes
complexes à poursuivre.
La justice,
elle a besoin de temps.
Que ça nous plaise ou non,
la justice a besoin de temps.
-On va y revenir.
Véronique Nahoum-Grappe,
comment vous réagissez à ce film ?
Il y a un travail de réparation
qui est à l'oeuvre,
avec ces témoignages.
On est peut-être même au-delà
de la question de la justice.
-Ce que je trouve formidable,
c'est quand une des personnes dit :
"Je veux que ça n'arrive plus jamais
sur la planète entière."
Oui, la justice est fragile,
oui, elle est lente,
oui, peut-être
qu'on sera tous morts
avant que le premier criminel
soit derrière les barreaux,
mais le rêve de justice
est énorme.
Le "plus jamais ça", on le traîne
depuis toujours, je crois.
Depuis 1945, au moins.
Au moins.
Mais je crois
qu'après chaque crime infâme,
il y a ces idées,
"plus jamais ça"
et "sur la planète entière".
Il y a cette question
du rêve de justice,
qui est impossible
à effacer de l'âme humaine.
-Qui est presque
aussi important que la justice.
-Exactement.
L'autre chose aussi
qui a été terrible
avec ces crimes,
c'est que toute torture
est un viol.
Tout viol est une torture,
dans ces conditions.
dans toutes les conditions.
Si vous voulez, il faut donner
la dignité du mot torture.
Ce qu'il y a de particulier,
c'est que contrairement
aux crimes non sexuels,
les crimes sexuels
ont un effet de souillure,
qui salit immédiatement
la victime.
Même une victime qui n'est pas
dans une idée très traditionnelle,
dans une société très traditionnelle
où la définition de la femme,
son honneur tient à sa sexualité,
elle est foutue.
Pendant tout l'Ancien Régime,
les viols sont suivis
de punition et d'infamie,
d'infamie sociale de la femme
ou de la jeune fille violée.
Et même encore,
les crimes d'honneur :
un père peut tuer sa fille de 16 ans
après avoir été violée.
C'est elle qui porte la souillure
sur l'ensemble de la famille.
Il n'y a pas que ça.
Même dans les sociétés
très évoluées.
On voit la dame qui dit :
"Je le fais,
"car je suis un peu âgée..."
-"Je parle parce que
je suis un peu âgée."
-Il y a une honte.
Ces crimes,
les crimes de souillure,
ils font basculer la salissure
dans le corps même de la victime.
Cette honte est une des choses
qui empêche vraiment,
pour ces crimes infernaux,
que le travail classique
de la justice,
comme dans les romans policiers,
puisse être fait normalement.
-Marianna Perebenesiuk,
le déclencheur
de la volonté de Zelensky
de faire travailler la justice
le plus vite possible,
c'est Boutcha
et les possibles charniers
qu'on a découverts
à la frontière russe ?
A partir de là,
le pouvoir ukrainien a décidé
qu'il fallait mettre le paquet
sur la justice ?
On voit que c'est très fragile,
mais il y a quand même
des procureurs
et des cas
qui sont regardés.
-Il y a plusieurs aspects à cela.
Je pense que les auteurs
de ce formidable documentaire,
qui nous a toutes frappées,
et j'espère
tous les spectateurs aussi,
peuvent en témoigner
également.
Il y a plusieurs raisons à cela.
Premièrement, l'Ukraine,
contrairement
à ce qu'on peut penser,
reste un Etat fonctionnel.
L'Ukraine a été
un Etat fonctionnel
dès les premiers jours
et tout au long de l'invasion,
ce qui est un exploit
en soi.
Deuxièmement,
on a déjà bien parlé,
surtout Mme Nahoum-Grappe,
c'est que la justice
est un aspect
extrêmement important.
Il ne s'agit pas
que de récupérer les territoires.
Il y a aussi
toute cette dimension-là...
-C'est une manière
de répondre à l'arbitraire
de la barbarie ?
-Exactement.
-Les Ukrainiens veulent répondre
par la justice.
-C'est un message.
-Exactement.
Par ailleurs, on peut aussi voir ça
dans la société ukrainienne.
Les Ukrainiens ne sont pas
pour une sorte de lynchage
ou pour des vendettas.
Les Ukrainiens sont
pour la justice en elle-même.
Par contre,
là où je ne serai
probablement pas d'accord,
c'est que...
La justice est-elle plus rapide
ou plus longue que d'habitude ?
D'après ce que je constate,
par rapport à ma connaissance
sur le rythme
de la justice du pays,
je suis...
étonnée de voir qu'elle suit
plus ou moins son rythme normal.
Plus ou moins.
Et ça...
-Quand l'officier russe Vadim
a été jugé, ça a été
le premier officier russe...
Il a tiré sur un cycliste.
Ce fut un procès très médiatique...
-Mais pour une affaire
aussi simple,
avec des témoins
et des preuves,
et en ayant un coupable,
ça s'est fait
en un mois et demi
ou deux mois.
Ca, ça peut être
très rapide,
en effet, en Ukraine, mais...
-Céline Bardet,
vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
-Non, je suis pas
complètement d'accord.
C'est Chichimarine.
Oui, c'était une affaire simple...
-Vadim Chichimarine.
-La question aussi,
c'est, par exemple...
Ici, on parle
de crimes internationaux.
Donc c'est ça, aussi.
L'intérêt, c'est de voir
si on peut remonter
des unités, etc.
L'histoire de Chichimarine...
D'abord, il a été condamné
à perpétuité en première instance.
Ensuite, ça a été changé.
-Il faut rappeler
les faits.
C'est un sous-officier russe
qui, en voiture,
a tiré à bout portant
sur un cycliste ukrainien.
-Sur un cycliste civil.
C'est constitutif de crime
de guerre, de tirer sur un civil.
Je suis d'accord
que les faits
étaient assez simples,
il les a reconnus, etc.
Ca a été jugé quand même
en trois jours, je crois.
Maintenant,
il aurait été intéressant
de savoir
quel est le contexte de ça,
s'il y avait d'autres personnes
avec lui...
Ce n'est pas
pour le discréditer
ou le décharger,
mais c'est ça.
Il y a aussi
la question de la peine.
Je suis d'accord
qu'au moins,
il y a une vraie démarche
d'aller dans la justice.
En ça, je suis très admirative
de l'Ukraine.
Comme vous le rappelez,
c'est un Etat qui reste fonctionnel
malgré la situation.
-Reprenons un tout petit peu
les termes.
On va revenir
aux crimes sexuels,
mais pour que l'on comprenne,
un crime de guerre...
C'est d'une ampleur inédite.
Il faut revenir à la Yougoslavie
pour retrouver cette ampleur.
C'est quoi,
un crime de guerre ?
-C'est tout crime qui est commis
à l'encontre d'un civil.
Ca peut être
un mauvais traitement
d'un prisonnier combattant,
aussi.
Toutes ces formes,
sur un terrain de conflit,
ça constitue
les crimes de guerre.
-Les crimes contre l'humanité,
génocidaires, supposent
une intention politique d'exterminer
la population,
en partie ou en totalité,
ou pas complètement,
mais de l'exterminer
dans son identité collective,
dans son passé
et dans son avenir.
Or les viols en temps de guerre,
où il y a beaucoup de témoignages
qui montrent
des acteurs dire "tu n'auras plus
d'enfant ukrainien",
et qui sont en lien
avec cette idée
qu'on enlève aussi le passé...
Le tyran adore être présent
pour l'éternité,
"jadis" et "à jamais".
Il laboure les cimetières,
il brûle les livres d'école,
il change l'histoire,
et sa façon d'envahir l'avenir,
l'arbre de filiation
de la communauté,
dont il veut anéantir
le nom, la présence,
même s'il ne tue pas
tout le monde,
c'est faire l'enfant
de l'ennemi,
envahir l'arbre de filiation,
faire l'enfant de l'ennemi
à la femme pour envahir l'avenir.
Elle sera russifiée.
Elle aura un Russe.
En même temps,
c'est entièrement faux.
C'est une croyance.
C'est pour les anthropologues.
Le fils n'hérite pas
des qualités morales du père
ou la fille de la mère.
On voit bien qu'il y a
une dissymétrie, un problème
avec cette croyance.
-Sur le crime sexuel
en temps de guerre,
la question, c'est...
On comprend
la signification symbolique,
à laquelle vous vous référez,
mais c'est la question
de l'intention,
ainsi que celle de l'ordre.
-Ce que je veux dire,
c'est que "génocide"
a une définition sérieuse
pour les juristes.
Il signifie
"assassinat de la naissance".
Il me semble
que cette définition littérale,
sans ambition,
modeste en quelque sorte,
mais littérale,
peut être réfléchie aussi
au plan juridique.
Les crimes
et les viols massifs,
jamais punis, encouragés...
On n'aura jamais les ordres,
mais si on décore le bataillon
qui est allé à Boutcha,
c'est bien qu'on reconnaît
que tous ces crimes
sont licites
et sont presque applaudis.
Donc, ça veut dire qu'il y a,
avec ces viols en temps de guerre,
une tentative d'anéantir
l'avenir imaginaire
de la collectivité.
-Donc l'anthropologue
que vous êtes
ne dit pas,
comme on entend beaucoup :
"Attention, génocide...
"On verra après
si c'est vraiment un génocide.
"C'est trop tôt..."
-Non, moi je trouve que là,
on est à un an de guerre,
on a une série de témoignages...
La notion de génocide a été inventée
à cause de l'exceptionnalité
des crimes des nazis.
Il y a de l'exceptionnalité.
Il faut être souple.
Il faut pas considérer
que le génocide est une vache sacrée
à laquelle
on ne doit plus toucher,
ce qui protégerait
tous les génocides
qu'on aurait pas le droit
de nommer...
"Merci, Hitler, de nous protéger,
futurs génocideurs !"
Moi, je suis pour
qu'on utilise cet outil,
qui est un outil efficace,
et je pense que dans ce cas-là,
l'idée d'anéantir
la nation ukrainienne
en tant qu'ukrainienne,
d'enlever les enfants,
de mettre des passeports russes,
de les russifier,
c'est une dimension génocidaire,
non pas physique, pas comme Hitler,
mais au moins, comment dire...
Politique.
Le mot "symbolique"
ne serait pas adéquat,
mais en tant que nationalité,
c'est anéantir
une identité collective.
-Anéantir une nation entière
en tant que nation,
et on pourrait dire
les femmes pour les crimes sexuels,
ou même les hommes,
les réduire au silence...
La question, maintenant...
On entend l'anthropologue,
mais comment on poursuit ça ?
Sur quels fondements ?
-Bah voilà.
Est-ce qu'un tribunal pénal
international spécifique...
Est-ce qu'il y a
les moyens
de montrer, de prouver
que ça fait partie d'une forme
de chaîne de commandement,
d'une atmosphère ?
Je vous fais réagir,
mais on a retrouvé les mots
de Vladimir Poutine
juste avant l'entrée en guerre.
-"Ma jolie".
-Ca, c'est quelque chose
qui est très impressionnant.
Ces mots, issus d'une chanson
du folklore russe,
adressés à Volodymyr Zelensky.
On va les retrouver.
Quand on dit ça,
avec cette violence-là...
-Un petit détail.
Dans la fameuse chanson,
ça s'adresse
à une femme décédée.
Pour ajouter de l'horreur
à l'horreur,
dans la chanson,
ça s'adresse à une femme décédée
dans son cercueil.
-Oui.
-Ilioné Schultz,
est-ce qu'il y a, au fond,
une forme de continuum
entre le chef du Kremlin,
quelque chose qui,
dans les mots,
dans l'atmosphère...
On voit Wagner
et la barbarie de ses soldats
qui sortent de prison,
qui sont des assassins,
et le terrain.
-Pour l'instant,
ce qui commence à émerger,
en tout cas dans les mots
des procureurs sur place,
c'est qu'ils commencent à parler
d'implication du commandement,
notamment
dans les crimes sexuels.
Dans les experts
qui sont aussi sur place,
on commence à parler
d'un faisceau d'indices
sur le fait
que dans près de 30 dossiers,
il y aurait des signes
de consentement du commandement.
Ca, c'est des éléments...
Les procureurs
citent aussi le fait
qu'on ait retrouvé
des préservatifs,
que des soldats russes
seraient venus avec,
qu'il y aurait eu
de la torture sexuelle
en détention,
avec la torture sur les...
Sur les organes génitaux,
pardon.
Mais, en revanche,
pour les experts qu'on a suivis
sur place, c'est beaucoup trop tôt.
Les enquêtes en sont
à un stade initial.
Il n'y a pas encore
de preuves
d'un plan préconçu,
politique, etc.
-Il y a une culture du viol.
Dans l'armée russe,
il y a cette pratique
du bizutage,
où les jeunes gens sont violés
dans une grande violence,
avec des morts.
Cette culture du viol
qui est étudiée,
qui est cette imprécation
entre la culture du KGB
et la culture des truands...
Déjà Soljenitsyne en parlait.
Le monde politique,
le discours politique du Kremlin,
avec le pouvoir poutinien,
la séduction, c'est ce côté
culture de la virilité.
C'est des masculinistes russes
qui trouvent que le viol,
c'est une performance.
Cette culture,
qui met l'humour de son côté,
la blague, etc.,
les moqueries...
-Ca a fini par pénétrer
toute la société.
Ca, c'est l'anthropologue,
mais on va regarder la juriste
si on veut
poursuivre les auteurs.
-Tout ça,
ce sont des éléments,
ce qu'a dit Poutine aussi,
évidemment.
D'abord,
quand on parle de justice,
on parle de tribunal.
Quand on parle de tribunal,
on parle de qualification juridique.
Pardon de ramener à ça.
J'entends ce qui est dit
sur la définition de génocide,
mais aujourd'hui, on a
des définitions juridiques
dans lesquelles
il faut lier des éléments
qui constituent un crime
à un auteur de crime.
C'est ça, la justice pénale
internationale.
-Vous avez une expérience
sur cette question
des crimes sexuels
dans les conflits.
A quels conflits
ça vous fait penser,
par le passé,
ce recours au viol
aujourd'hui en Ukraine ?
-Il y en a plein,
en fait.
-On pense à la Libye,
à la Syrie.
C'est comparable ?
-Déjà, ce qui a été dit là...
J'ai beaucoup travaillé
sur le viol des hommes
en Libye,
l'utilisation de toutes formes
de torture sexuelle,
c'est pour ça que "crimes sexuels",
c'est important, c'est utilisé.
On l'a vu dans les Balkans,
en Bosnie-Herzégovine.
Le viol a été un outil de génocide
au Rwanda.
Il y a plein de situations.
Aujourd'hui, on viole
dans énormément de pays.
Mon ONG travaille
sur le monde entier,
je vous invite
à regarder notre carte.
-Donc on est là-dedans,
mais il faut trouver
les moyens de poursuivre.
-L'Ukraine,
on est en plein conflit.
Un travail de documentation
est fait. On voit une forme
de systématisation.
Ce ne sont pas que des ordres.
On cherche celui qui a écrit
sur un papier "allez-y, violez".
Mais comme ce qui a été dit
juste avant,
ce qu'on regarde, c'est :
est-ce que c'est
systématisé, répété,
est-ce qu'à chaque fois
que les soldats russes
arrivent quelque part,
il y a des viols ?
Je pense que ça,
c'est assez établi,
mais ça reste à affirmer.
C'est ça qu'il faut voir.
Et aussi,
le fait qu'au niveau des unités,
au-dessus dans la hiérarchie,
on laisse faire.
Si on laisse faire...
-C'est constitutif.
-...on peut être poursuivi pour viol
comme élément constitutif
de crime contre l'humanité.
-Marianna Perebenesiuk.
-Puisqu'on va
sur le terrain
de parallèles,
à la fois de la tradition
de l'armée russe,
déjà, cette sortie
de Vladimir Poutine,
avec ce refrain de chanson,
elle est déjà très réminiscente
d'une chanson
qui avait été écrite
pendant l'invasion
de la Finlande en 39,
dont le refrain était :
"Prends-nous,
Finlande la beauté."
Donc on traite la Finlande
comme une femme à violer,
une femme belle, donc moi,
le soldat russe,
"prends-moi".
C'est pour dire qu'en réalité,
le viol est une...
caractéristique
et une longue tradition
au sein de l'armée russe,
et non pas depuis 10 ans,
mais depuis des décennies.
On rappelle par ailleurs
tous les viols
qui ont été commis
par l'armée soviétique...
-A Berlin.
-...en Allemagne nazie.
On se rappelle que le prétexte
de l'invasion de l'Ukraine,
c'était la prétendue
dénazification,
une sorte de réactivation
de ce mode opératoire...
-Le mot de génocide
a même été employé
par Poutine, au début.
-On se rappelle
tous les crimes de guerre,
y compris les crimes sexuels,
qui ont été commis
par l'armée russe,
à commencer par
la première guerre de Tchétchénie,
où quasiment toute la population,
hommes, femmes, enfants,
les captifs étaient
systématiquement violés.
On a jamais payé
assez attention à cela.
-Vous nous dites
beaucoup de choses,
notamment sur cette culture du viol
en Russie.
Maintenant,
comment on fait ?
On a l'impression,
Céline Bardet, qu'il y a déjà
beaucoup d'enquêteurs,
un enchevêtrement
de plein de strates d'enquêteurs,
des ONG,
il y a la Cour pénale
internationale,
il y a des juristes internationaux.
Ca, il faut le faire,
il faut se coordonner,
mais il faut faire vite
pour recueillir les preuves,
qui peuvent disparaître.
Vous êtes d'accord là-dessus,
sur le recueil des traces ?
-Evidemment que c'est important
de faire vite, bien sûr,
mais sur la singularité
des crimes sexuels,
et c'est ce que le documentaire
montre excellemment bien,
c'est qu'il y a un traumatisme,
il y a une peur des représailles,
en l'occurrence en Ukraine,
mais ça, c'est partout.
Je travaille dans le monde entier.
Dans tous les conflits
dans le monde...
-On en fait trop sur l'Ukraine ?
-Non, on en parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui, et tant mieux.
Ce qui se passe
mérite qu'on en parle,
mais il faut comprendre
que le viol est devenu un outil,
un mécanisme de la guerre
et du conflit, et effectivement,
il faut qu'on arrive
à en prendre conscience.
-Quel tribunal ?
Comment poursuivre ?
Faut-il laisser
la justice ukrainienne ?
Un tribunal spécifique ?
Faut-il essayer de poursuivre
un maximum de chefs devant la CPI ?
Il y a déjà beaucoup
d'ouvertures de procédures.
-Oui. Aujourd'hui,
il y a
le parquet ukrainien
qui est compétent,
il y a la CPI, on parle d'ouvrir
un parquet européen pour travailler
aux crimes d'agression,
qui est autre chose
et qui va concerner beaucoup plus
Poutine et les haut gradés.
Je pense que le parquet ukrainien
peut très bien faire son travail.
Après, la question
va pas tant être de documenter
les éléments de preuve,
on en a plein et les crimes
sont multiples et horribles.
La question, ça va être l'analyse,
on oublie souvent ça.
Je suis enquêtrice criminelle
internationale
et il y a l'étape d'analyse.
Aujourd'hui,
il y a énormément d'éléments.
Ca prend du temps
de les analyser,
de faire le lien
dont je vous ai parlé.
La justice,
c'est poursuivre un individu,
donc il faut lier cet individu
à ce crime.
Donc voilà...
-Il faudra déterminer
la qualification aussi.
-Il faut qualifier.
-Crime de guerre, génocide,
crime contre l'humanité.
-Et l'agression,
comme la CPI
n'est pas compétente pour l'Ukraine
sur le crime d'agression,
on a cette discussion
de créer un tribunal spécial.
Je pense
que la volonté de l'Ukraine
est qu'il y ait un tribunal spécial
comme il y a eu
pour l'ex-Yougoslavie
ou le Rwanda,
ce qui permettrait peut-être
d'être une solution
parce que la Cour pénale
internationale...
Je crois qu'on en est à
70 000 dossiers
ouverts au parquet ukrainien.
-75 000.
-Comment voulez-vous
que n'importe qui,
n'importe quel pays dans le monde,
puisse travailler
sur 70 000 ou 75 000 dossiers ?
C'est pas possible.
Donc il faut...
-Il faut des renforts
juridictionnels,
avec des tribunaux spéciaux.
-Oui, il faut les aider,
et il faut réfléchir aussi
à d'autres formes de justice.
Si on a des masses de crimes,
il y a d'autres manières
de rendre la justice.
Il y a des commissions,
il y a la justice transitionnelle...
Toutes les victimes
n'attendent pas
que les auteurs de crime
aillent en prison.
C'était intéressant,
dans le documentaire,
cette femme qui dit :
"Je parle
"parce que je veux pas
que ça arrive aux autres."
Beaucoup de victimes me disent
qu'elles croient pas à la justice.
-Elles ne croient pas
que les auteurs
des faits
soient poursuivis.
D'ailleurs, la plupart des procès
aujourd'hui se font par contumace.
-Parce que l'Ukraine
le permet,
mais la politique des procureurs
en ce moment, c'est de dire :
on laissera le choix à la victime.
Est-ce qu'elle veut un procès
en Ukraine là maintenant ou pas ?
Toutes les victimes
n'ont pas envie
forcément d'un procès.
-Donc ça,
vous l'avez vraiment
ressenti ? Les victimes,
elles veulent avant tout parler
pour que ça n'arrive plus,
presque davantage
que pour recevoir
la justice,
un procès ?
-Oui, complètement,
et surtout,
on parle de 75 000 crimes de guerre,
mais les crimes de guerre
à caractère sexuel,
si on regarde dans l'histoire
de la justice internationale,
ce sont souvent pas ceux-là
qui sont jugés
en priorité,
donc les victimes
ne sont pas naïves
sur le cours que va prendre
la justice, et nationale,
et internationale.
-Vous aurez le mot de la fin,
Véronique Nahoum-Grappe.
-Même pour les viols
en temps de paix,
la justice, les procès
ont une difficulté,
parce que cette question
des preuves,
cette question des témoignages,
de la honte qui pèse
sur les victimes...
Donc en temps de guerre,
pour démontrer
une chaîne de commandement
pour des pratiques
qui sont tacites,
qui sont en dehors du langage
et des écrits, à mon avis...
Excusez-moi.
A mon avis, ça va être
très, très difficile.
Donc on peut comprendre
que du côté des victimes
qui rêvent
de justice,
il y ait cette idée que témoigner,
faire des films,
en attendant
que le boulot de la justice
soit fait, c'est déjà
un premier pas...
énorme.
-Oui, dans le travail
de reconstruction de soi,
de réparation.
-Ce qui est intéressant
dans le fait
de faire ces enquêtes
alors que le conflit continue,
c'est qu'il y a toute une question
sur la récolte des preuves,
on parle vraiment des crimes
à caractère sexuel,
parce que les femmes, on va voir
plus vite s'il y a eu viol,
et il va y avoir tout ce travail
en open source,
avec les téléphonies,
les réseaux sociaux.
-Le numérique
a changé les choses.
-Ca change beaucoup les choses.
-La question que les gens se posent
aussi, c'est : est-ce qu'un jour,
Poutine pourra être traduit devant
un tribunal pénal international ?
-Possible.
Il peut y avoir
un acte d'accusation.
S'il y a un changement politique,
il peut se retrouver
devant un tribunal,
comme Milosevic.
Ce qui est important aussi,
c'est d'être à l'écoute
de ces victimes,
de ce qu'elles veulent,
de ce dont elles ont besoin
et du temps dont elles ont besoin.
Leur temps, c'est pas le même,
et les crimes sexuels,
c'est très difficile.
Il y a des victimes qui peuvent
avoir été violées aujourd'hui
et qui parleront
bien plus longtemps
après.
-Votre film leur donne ce temps
et cet espace de reconnaissance.
Merci beaucoup.
-Merci à vous.
-Merci d'être venues
débattre autour
de votre documentaire,
Ilioné Schultz
et Marine Courtade.
C'est la fin
de cette soirée événement
autour de la première année
de conflit en Ukraine.
Bonsoir à tous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...